WHILE HE IS IN OFFICE.
THE HOUSE UNANIMOUSLY IS
CALLING FOR THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO RELEASE THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S RUSSIA
COLLUSION REPORT ONCE IT'S
FINISHED.
THERE ARE NEW INDICATIONS
TONIGHT THAT MIGHT BE VERY
SOON.
HERE IS CHIEF INTELLIGENCE
CORRESPONDENT CATHERINE
HERRIDGE.
>> A SPOKESMAN FOR SPECIAL
COUNSEL MUELLER CONFIRMS
THAT TOP PROSECUTOR ANDREW
WEISSMAN IS STEPPING DOWN IN
WHAT MAY BE THE LATEST CLUE
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION IS
WINDING DOWN.
BUT THE TIMING ALSO REFLECTS
THAT FORMER CAMPAIGN
CHAIRMAN PAUL MANAFORT'S
SENTENCING IS NOW COMPLETE
IN D.C. AND VIRGINIA.
WEISSMAN WAS THE LEAD
PROSECUTOR.
AND WEISSMAN WAS ALSO IN
COURT TODAY AS POLITICAL
OPERATIVE ROGER STONE
LEARNED HIS TRIAL DATE IS
SET FOR NOVEMBER 5TH.
>> THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
>> THE YEAS ARE 420, THE
NAYS ARE ZERO.
>> ON THE HOUSE FLOOR WITH
RARE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT,
LAWMAKERS VOTED IN FAVOR OF
A NONBINDING RESOLUTION TO
INCOURAGE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WILLIAM BARR TO RELEASE
MUELLER'S FULL REPORT TO
BOTH CONGRESS AND THE
COUNTRY.
>> A VOTE FOR THIS
RESOLUTION WILL SEND A CLEAR
SIGNAL TO BOTH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE THAT CONGRESS
BELIEVES TRANSPARENCY IS A
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLE
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT
GOVERNMENT REMAINS
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PUBLIC.
>> THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
STATUTE KNOWN AS 26 CR 600
SANDY CONFIDENTIAL REPORT TO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
DURING CONFIRMATION HEARINGS
HE LAID CONFIRMATION TELLING
LAWMAKERS HE WOULD SUMMARIZE
NOT SEND MUELLER'S FINDINGS
TO CONGRESS AND RELEASE AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE TO THE
PUBLIC.
>> IT'S NOTHING BUT A
RESTATEMENT OF THE
REGULATION.
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR WILL
FOLLOW THE REGULATION.
HE HAS SAID SO.
>> THE LEAD REPUBLICAN ON
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE DOUG
COLLINS ALSO RELEASED MORE
TRANSCRIPTS FROM A HOUSE
PROBE INTO THE 2016 ACTIONS
OF THE FBI AND DOJ.
FBI AGENT PETER STRZOK
DISMISS FROM THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL FOR HIS ANTI-TRUMP
TEXTS TOLD LAWMAKERS MUELLER
NEVER PRESSED HIM ON
POLITICAL BIAS.
REPUBLICAN JOHN RATCLIFFE
ASKED DID YOU HAVE ANY
DISCUSSION WITH SPECIAL
COUNSEL MUELLER OR THE OTHER
ATTORNEY ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT THOSE TEXT MESSAGES
REFLECTED BIAS OR PREJUDICE
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP?
STRZOK:  NO.
>> ACCORDING TO THE STRZOK
TRANSCRIPT THERE WAS A
NEGOTIATED CONSENT AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND CLINTON
LAWYERS THAT LAID DOWN
GROUND RULES FOR FBI ACCESS
TO PERSONAL SERVERS USED FOR
STATE DEPARTMENT BUSINESS.